Hey! Oh, no, I can't
I can't hear you, Haley, at all.
Unmute.
Yeah.
Hello, hello, hello.
Nice to hear you.
Hello!
So nice to meet you.
I am Rawson Marshall Thurber,
and I'm here talking with
Haley Hope Bartels, who just
won the Nicholl Fellowship
for her fantastic script
Pumping Black.
it is about an aging
cyclist in the 1990s
who, when threatened
with being cut from
his team right before
the Tour de France,
takes up a dangerous offer
from a team doctor
to engage in doping.
Congratulations on
Pumping Black and on being
being a Nicholls Fellow
I am-
Every morning I wake up
and I'm waiting for someone to be like,
there's been a huge mistake.
But it's so far, it's held so far. So-
Ah yeah, it's not a very
elaborate episode of Punk’d.
Yeah.
So tell me a little bit
about submitting
and what that
process was like.
Yeah, so I graduated AFI in 2019.
A couple months after that,
the pandemic hit.
Perfect.
and it was mostly
like a sea of no's.
Applying to the Nicholl this year,
I almost didn’t do it.
Because I was like, “I keep sending
things to competitions and
people keep saying no.”
I asked my boyfriend, like,
“Should I apply that?
Should he even apply
to the Nicholl this year?”
He’s like “Yes, you have to do it.”
And I was like, “But they're not
going to like it like they never like it.”
He's like, “You have to apply.
You just have to do it.”
Good boyfriend.
What do you think it was
about Pumping Black
that the deciders liked that
they maybe didn't see
in your previous writing?
This script is much more
specific and weird, I think.
Even though it's  a very
fantastical, sort of specific
world of professional cycling
in which I have never personally lived
the element of perfectionism
and obsession, I think that came out
in this script in a way
that it hasn’t in my other writing.
It's a whole world of
doping and racing in
the Tour de France,
but there's not much of a mention
of the one and only Lance Armstrong.
That's very intentional. Yeah.
Yeah.
The story of Lance Armstrong
is the doping story that everybody knows.
Maybe people know Barry Bonds.
I'm a Giants fan like-
Me too.
Oh, how are you doing?
Not great. Not great.
Yeah, me neither
Well, you know, it's a it's
a really powerful screenplay
it's all really, really juicy stuff
and beautifully rendered in your work.
So I'm not surprised in the least
that you were selected
so congratulations.
For you and your writing,
what would you find is the most
challenging part of it for you?
Is it the beginning?
Is it finishing or
do you get mired in the middle?
I'm so happy you asked.
We have a big, huge like
eight-by-five whiteboard
and I put my nine beats up
or if I'm doing a pilot
and that is the most difficult part.
And once I've done that for
two, three, six months, then I can
write a scripts in a week.
Like pumping black,
like first draft for it in a week.
It took me six months
to write it in a week.
I would love your advice
on, you know, as somebody
who's been very successful
in the industry
since at least 2006,
Dodgeball is awesome, by the way.
My dad still quotes
that movie all the time.
Tell you your dad,
I'm a big fan of his.
He sounds like a very smart man.
Yeah, he's a genius
That sounded sarcastic, but he is.
He is a very smart man.
Success in this town and maybe success
and any competitive field,
you know, really comes
down to three things
as far as I have been
able to suss out.
And it's hard work, luck and talent.
You put in the hours, you know,
your butt in the seat
working on, you know,
on your screenplay.
And then I found that the harder
I work, the luckier I've gotten.
You could have not
written Pumping Black.
You could have not submitted it,
had your boyfriend not
made you do it.
But you could have not, right?
Like you could have said, “I'm tired
of being passed on and I'm going to go”
You know, but you didn't.
And thank goodness
for that, right?
What are you doing next?
What's the plan?
Yeah. Well, I’ve got to write a script
for the Nicoll Committee
over the next year.
Oh yeah?
Yeah, I’ve got to do that.
I haven't decided
what that's going to be yet.
I wish you all the best
and congratulations
on winning the Nicholl
and I'm stoked for you.
And good luck.
Truly, like this has been so delightful
and I had the best time.
Thank you again.
Thank you. Thank you.
And go Giants!
Giants.
Giants. Next year.
We're going to get it.
Yes. Yes, ma'am. See you later.